some people think the cloud is actually
a cloud
for others it's an ethereal mystery the
place where your photos and documents
get sucked to and hang out
this dough is the cloud
at least the physical manifestation of
it it's thousands of servers and storage
systems working together to hold our
information this is where all the action
happens this is where all our photos are
like so this is really where Facebook is
actually running look around see over
there it's a picture of a young Ashley
Vance who thought that going blonde
would be a good idea and that one it's a
lingering poke from your creepy ex and
right there is an inspirational meme
helping lift people's spirits where does
my mom find all these amazing quotes and
because we built the infrastructure to
be so redundant we can basically pull
any server and it's not going to affect
any end user in in any negative way so
we pull one out here okay so we're going
to take down Facebook
typical Monday ah but it's all built to
be as energy and cooling efficient as
possible so there are no fans at all on
this one as you can see they're sort of
it's just working on their pressure
difference that forces here through I
think for most people who've never been
to a data center they're usually like
these big sort of pizza box things with
tons of fans and moving parts going on
them and you guys compacted everything
down if the industry in general started
adopting a lot more of this thinking it
could really change the whole industry
and not just Facebook a couple of
corridors we'll go through a typical
data center relies on massive
air-conditioning units to pump cool air
onto tens of thousands of computers
can't pay for this kind of wind blowing
look Facebook is too hip for that
[Applause]
I'm gonna catch up it uses cool arctic
air to keep its photo friend and like
machines for melting down this whole
place lends itself to Sweden's
meticulous attention to detail and
design the building is an engineering
marvel that treats air like a pampered
Corgi poo the air gets sucked in cleaned
watered and then sent on its way via
physics with the building pressure
pushing the air down onto the computers
since facebook gives away its service
for free this place needs to operate as
smoothly and cheaply as possible to
minimize the cost of each click
[Music]
[Music]